this is really interesting I did not
know this until Indira launch went on
beat it into my head a number of years
ago well the talks in Vienna they're not
going well and you know this side
disagrees to agree with the other side
and all that the backdrop is something
different and in the Middle East Iran
and Persia are well there are complete
society that the 18th and purchasing
power parity in the world they have a
fully developed middle class this is
really different bring up the single
best chart and this is nothing more than
per capita GDP and up they go here's the
log chart so slope matters you get up to
that big peak in the 80s down they go
and then the recovery with oil and gas
has been stupendous until now and
they've really rolled over Brendan they
have rolled over this is the hardship
that Tehran has is that go into these
talks I think it's interesting when you
talk about you know a complete society
in the Middle East this is one of the
things that we hear from people are our
goal and our motive ollie reporting from
the street in Tehran they really like
Americans that there is a natural
kinship to Americans on the street in in
in Tehran Chris Davidson at Durham in
talking about the United Arab Emirates
and all that is adamant at the
development for rent and it is separate
and distinct from everything else to the
west of course single biggest factor in
Iran's development right now is whether
or not they're going to be able to shuck
off those sanctions as part of a big
deal we have in dear lachman on she's
joining us from Vienna Indira what we're
hearing right now the disagreement over
the arms embargo between the US and
Russia is that just dotting i's and
crossing T's or is that really standing
in the way of an agreement right now I
think that's one of several things that
are standing in the way we heard from
senior Iranian officials last night
their claim was that there had been
actually a tentative agreement on
Wednesday and that yesterday the United
States had sort of rolled back the terms
harden their positions and wanted more
and the Iranians suspect that perhaps
there was some conversation in that
conference call between President Obama
and John Kerry and perhaps President
Obama said
no we can't accept those conditions we
can't sell them in Congress you need to
go harder line the United States for its
part denied that and said there never
had been a deal so indeed as you said we
are deadlocked here they missed the
deadline this morning for getting the
deal to Congress which would have given
them a fast-track review and at this
point we're looking at a day-by-day
situation but we're automatically
looking at doubling the time that Iran
will have to wait for sanctions relief
from at least one month of this review
22 months for Congress so right now it's
not looking great in terms of how talks
are going in dear having missed this
deadline for congressional review what
will be the consequences what does it
mean that Congress has more time to take
a look at this deal and how aware of it
are they Indiana where you are well
they're very aware of it in Vienna and
the consequence principally is that
Congress will have twice as much time to
pick over and potentially reject the
deal ultimately the president can of
course veto their rejection and it's not
clear that there will be enough votes in
Congress to override that presidential
veto but the larger point is here that
polling shows the American people want a
deal with Iran they want to prevent Iran
from getting a nuclear weapon and they
think that negotiations are the best way
to do it the sentiment on Capitol Hill
is somewhat different where there is a
real attachment to sanctions and using
those as a tool of corrosion and that's
something that the Iranian officials
complained to us about last night saying
that they need to let go of that
attachment to sanctions if they want
this deal done indira the discussion is
technocratic and political how large is
religion is a backdrop for the Iranian
side
I actually think it's not at all in this
point it really is they're being very
pragmatic about it they want the best
possible they can deal that they can get
and that's on the nuclear piece that's
on the sanctions relief piece it's also
on the arms embargo they want
conventional weapons they say they need
them to fight Isis so you know I think
it's really for Iran a very terrible
braddock practical decision here about
getting the best deal